I don't feed my kids candy because they're loaded with food dyes,
high fructose corn syrup, extreme amounts of refined sugar,
and toxic chemicals. Which is why I'm making them homemade Reese's.
Just because store bought candy is pretty much off limits
doesn't mean the homemade candy is.
Reese's takes just a few ingredients,
all nourishing and nutrient dense,
and we can enjoy them whenever we want to do this.
I roasted some walnuts, as peanuts are high in aflatoxins,
and then whipped up some homemade chocolate
which we all licked up pretty darn good.
Meow! This homemade chocolate was just five real ingredients
and took seconds to make. Next,
I lined a mini muffin tray with mini muffin liners.
I drizzled a little bit of my chocolate into the bottom of each,
then stuck those in the freezer for a few minutes until firm.
I used a food processor to turn the roasted walnuts into walnut butter
and then rated the Reese's filling with the walnut butter, butter,
coconut sugar, and coconut flour.
I stirred the mixture until smooth
and set it in the freezer until firm.
Rolled out little pieces of walnut filling
and placed each little ball on top of the firm chocolate lined cups.
I then went through and flattened the ball slightly,
making sure to keep the disc smaller and radius than the chocolate.
Lastly, I went through
and filled each of the cups with the remaining chocolate.
They set in the freezer for 15 minutes until hardened.
Then we devoured a few and saved the rest for another day.